Sebastián Piñera is already president, well,
actually, he’s president again, because
as you all know...
this political leader was President of Chile
barely 2 mandates ago... between 2010 and 2014
"Today is a great day for Chile."
Now, after achieving a strong and healthy
victory by almost 10 points in the 2017 presidential elections
Sebastián Piñera was declared president
on March 11.
Well, dear viewers, in this video we’ll
see what kind of Chile this president is inheriting,
as well as
the great challenges that lie ahead.
But first of all, let’s get to know this
character better, let's see who Sebastián
Piñera is.
WHO IS SEBASTIÁN PIÑERA?
First of all, we need to know that Sebastián
Piñera, for many reasons, isn’t just another
politician.
See, we’re talking about a man who, on the
one hand, owns one of the biggest fortunes
in Chile.
A fortune that Forbes magazine estimates,
is no less than 2.7 billion dollars.
You heard that right.
(SUBTITLES FOR A CLIP: "I’ve always rebelled
against those who want to separate the entrepreneurial
spirit from the government.
It seems absurd to me that they prefer a government
full of political
operators and that has no honest entrepreneurs.
For the first to be able to run for everything,
while the
others can’t run at all.)
For years, Sebastián Piñera was an aggressive,
self-made businessman.
But don’t be fooled by his Colgate smile...
his record shows that for a long time Piñera
knew how to play
to the limit and become a major investor in
various sectors, such as construction, supermarkets,
airlines
and TV channels.
Yes, now that I think about it, it’s hard
to find a sector in which Piñera didn’t try his luck...
Even in 2006, he decided to bet on the football industry and took control of a team... but
not any team,
the most important soccer team in Chile, the Colo-Colo.
Of course many critics accuse him of buying this team not as an investment, but as a political
maneuver,
like Silvio Berlusconi.
But don’t think that Piñera’s exploits
were only in the business sector, not at all.
In the political arena, the current President
of Chile also left his mark.
In 2010 he became the first
right-wing president to be democratically
elected since 1958.
Piñera also became the first right-wing president since Chile underwent its democratic transition
after
Augusto Pinochet’s era.
Now, in 2018, this is happening again.
In other words, we could say that Sebastián
Piñera is a fortunate guy, don’t you think?
Well, the fact is that in his first stage,
despite having to face the consequences of
a terrible
earthquake that shook his country just 2 weeks before his investiture, his first government
had relatively good results.
"At least half of our efforts throughout the
entire administration were devoted to rebuilding
the country
and consequently, we had to sacrifice many
things we wanted to do”, Rodrigo Hinzpeter,
Minister of the
Interior and Minister of Defense in Sebastián Piñera’s first government
The truth is that no great revolutionary change really happened, however, in his 4 years of government,
the economy grew by more than 5% per year,
more than 1 million jobs were created, wages
increased and
poverty fell sharply.
AUDIO: "We had a really good government, in
which every social and economic indicator
improved in Chile,
but I have more experience now, and experience
counts."
Sebastián Piñera.
And the truth is my friends, that in this
case, all that experience can be very, very
important, why?
Well... because today’s Chile is quite different.
Listen up.
TODAY’S CHILE
We already told you here on VISUALPOLITIK
and of course I don’t think this will surprise
anyone.
In the last few decades, Chile has been something
like Latin America’s Cristiano Ronaldo,
the country
that grew the most, the one that had the most
success.
Convincing proof of this was the evolution
of the Chilean middle class, which multiplied
by almost 3
times within a very short span.
"The Chilean middle class grew from 23.7%
to 64.3% of the population in 25 years" Diario Exterior
However, as we saw here in a previous video, in recent years, specifically during Michelle Bachelet’s
last term, things changed.
"Chile is a medium-sized country that hasn’t yet been able to fully develop, but its accelerated
modernization in recent decades has put us squarely on the frontier of modernity’s
challenges and the
tensions that democracy and economic growth face.
Just as we mentioned, in recent years economic growth has plummeted, job creation has slowed
down, wages
haven’t grown and foreign investment has
dropped.
Lately, the only thing that has grown in Chile have been the number of public employees,
taxes and
bureaucracy.
That's right, practically every economic parameter
made a very negative change during Michelle
Bachelet’s
last term.
Check this out:
For example, there has been an average growth
of barely 1.8% per year, which implies that
this
legislation was the worst in economic growth
terms since the democratic transition.
In fact, in recent years, Chile has grown
less than the world economy and considerably
less than its The
Pacific Alliance counterparts, Mexico, Peru
and Colombia.
And that's not all.
The public deficit went from being a guest
to a permanent tenant, and of course that
has consequences.
Public debt, although still low, has reached
its highest level since 1993.
"Having the fiscal debt double every four
years isn’t sustainable.
That’s the road to the precipice"
Felipe Larraín, Minister of Finance.)
Although, by far, the worst development has
been the 4-year consecutive drop in investments.
And it wasn’t only the economy that went
south.
Crime rates have increased a lot.
In the Araucanía region, where there’s
a conflict with the indigenous peoples -the
Mapuches, who demand
more autonomy and recognition- violent acts
have exploded, growing by 150%.
"What does the government want?
For citizens to have to organize armed militias
to protect themselves or
for them to take justice into their own hands?")
And even regarding health, the government's
decision to suspend the hospital concession
system has meant
that the government has barely been able to
invest more than half of what they’d budgeted...
making
waitlists and quality issues a chronic disease.
And... let's not deceive ourselves, as always,
the ones most affected by all of this aren’t
the richest,
but the middle class and even more so, the
most vulnerable population, the poor.
In other words, it’s fair to say that Chileans
have no reason to celebrate Michelle Bachelet’s
last term.
Those were a very intense 4 years!
Perhaps, we could see what’s happening in
Chile by taking a look at their economic freedom
index, whose
correlation with a country’s level of wealth
and prosperity is very high.
Well, during Michelle Bachelet’s last term,
Chile fell from the 7th position to the 20th.
Anyway, this is the Chile that the new president,
Sebastián Piñera, has to face.
Now the question we need
to ask ourselves is, what should this new
government’s priorities be?
What can we expect?
Well, let's
see.
"We need to bring the state closer to the
citizens".)
"How can a government be good if it’s holding
Chile stagnant, plunged into frustration,
doesn’t create
but destroys good jobs, and doesn’t improve
wages or pensions?")
THE
GREAT CHALLENGES
Well, it seems quite clear that in a country
that isn’t exactly cheap and in which 3
out of 4 workers
make less than USD 800 a month, the economy
has to be their number one priority.
If the economy isn’t doing well, social
statistics won’t do well either.
And this seems to be very, very clear for
the new government.
In fact, Sebastián Piñera, the new president,
has promised to focus his efforts on doubling
economic
growth, creating hundreds of jobs and laying
the foundations for Chile to become the first
developed
country in Latin America by 2025.
But, of course, you may be thinking, how can
he achieve this?
"I hope he doesn’t think that a mere tax
reform will it be enough to restore Chile’s
growth.
He is going
to need an aggressive policy to stimulate
diversification.
Almost half of the country's exports are still
copper" Ricardo Hausmann.)
Well, to achieve the 2025 goal, the country
needs to deal with 3 very clear priorities:
Diversify their economy; improve their productivity
and adjust their public accounts... but don’t
think
this is an easy task.
To diversify the economy, to stop relying
on raw materials, especially copper, and boost
their
productivity, Piñera's Chile will need a
few things:
First, they’ll need to promote investment,
especially foreign investment.
That is, attract more companies
and foreign capital who will bet on Chile
to produce and provide services.
This plan could really be helped by a reversal
of Bachelet’s terrible tax reform, which
not only raised
taxes on companies, but also punished their
investments.
Not a good idea!
Decreasing the huge bureaucracy by, for example,
digitizing every process, would help a lot
too.
Second... and this is a much more controversial
issue for this Latin American country... they’ll
need to
promote a program to attract foreign talent.
Yes, to promote immigration.
See, in Chile, the immigrant population has
grown a lot in recent years but it’s still
very low, and
hasn’t even reached 3% of the population.
And Chileans like to compare themselves with
Australia and New
Zealand, where immigrants make up to 30% of
the total population, 10 times more than Chile.
Yes, my friends, you heard that right.
The best way to gain talent and promote different
businesses and activities is to attract people
with
different skills and abilities from all over
the world.
We’ll discuss this in more detail soon,
but
here’s a prime example:
In Silicon Valley, the great global innovation
center, 54% of all entrepreneurs, that is,
more than half,
are foreigners.
And no, we’re not talking about an open
door, but about setting a mechanism in motion
that clarifies and
promotes talent attraction.
Because at the end of the day, if all goes
well, Chile can aspire to become the great
benchmark for
businesses in Latin America.... and that implies
attracting professionals.
In addition, and this is an important detail,
according to all Chilean statistics, immigrants
have more
education on average, their labor participation
is much higher and they earn more money.
Other policies Chile needs to enforce are
improving relations between universities and
companies; fight
insecurity rates; end public deficit; improve
infrastructure and increase savings.
Well, if we take a look at Sebastián Piñera's
program, we’ll see that the president's
promises seem to
run on this line... so, in principle, everything
a priori suggests that this political change
will be
good for Chile.
Of course, as we all know, only time will
tell.
But, just a moment, because not everything
will be so simple.
See, due to an Electoral Law reform Michelle
Bachelet promoted, Piñera's coalition doesn’t
have a
majority in Congress, so negotiating and seeking
parliamentary agreements will be a priority
for this new
government team.
So, my friends, that's the way things are,
but now it's your turn.
What’s your opinion on Sebastián Piñera’s
new government?
How do you think his government will be for
Chile?
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every Monday
and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And as always, thanks for watching!